the Backstreet Boys are officially
heading to Sin City and et was the first
to chat with AJ McLean about the band's
major comeback AJ says Britney Spears
inspired the group to finalize their Las
Vegas residency
he told ET she raved about her own
experience on her piece of me show coat
she literally said this is the best job
ever she said that it's hard work but
easy in the sense that you get to be
with your family
more than when you're on tour and have
somewhat of a normal life McLean also
dished on details for their highly
anticipated production adding quote
we're hopefully going to have some of
the biggest elements from all of our
biggest tours songs and shows it will be
the biggest show we've ever done in 24
years we literally want people
breathless as they lead something Nick
Carter teased when we chatted with him
back in April it would definitely have
to be a very big and spectacular show
and thankfully we have a good catalog so
we could perform all of our hits and
stuff and that that could take up a lot
of the show